ce camp de fortune a été construit dès
le début du conflit juste devant la gare
de lviv les récentes annonces du
gouvernement appelant les civils à fuir
l'est du pays et notamment la région du
donbass a propulsé sur la route des
dizaines des centaines de milliers de
réfugiés qui commencent déjà à arriver
ici
les gens là-bas vivent littéralement
sous les bombes un jour deux missiles
ont frappé ma maison un de chaque côté
c'est ce qui m'a poussé à partir
quitter sa maison l'endroit même où vous
êtes né ou s'inscrit chaque seconde de
votre existence
c'est très dur vous laisser tous
derrière vous
c'est impossible à supporter
après un voyage éprouvant de plusieurs
jours ces personnes sont accueillies ici
dans un centre de transit ils sont
enregistrés nourris soignés et peuvent
se reposer 24 heures avant d'être
répartis dans leur famille chez des amis
ou encore dans les différents centres
d'hébergement un petit peu partout dans
la région université ou églises
notamment pour l'instant nous n'avons
pas eu des problèmes avec la quantité
des places pour la nous avons assez de
passer de la nourriture à ces délits etc
voilà donc ça va nous faisons tout notre
possible au début de la guerre ils
étaient trente mille arrivé ici
quotidiennement et la situation
jusqu'ici a été plutôt bien gérée par
les autorités locales mais avec cette
nouvelle phase du conflit qui s'ouvre
dans l'est rien ne dit qu'ils ne seront
pas encore plus nombreux dans les jours
à venir c'est un véritable défi pour
toute la région